>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Tell us what you do here
at the Library of Congress?
>> Ok, I'm a reference librarian, so I get to
answer questions every day, and it's from people
who come in by person or by telephone
or over our Ask The Librarian
system and sometimes by email.
And I also teach a lot of classes on how to
use the library and do some outreach work.
>> Well, as a digital reference
specialist here at the library,
I focus on helping our online users access and
understand the information that can be found
on our website, including our primary
and secondary source materials.
I also staff, like Abby, the Ask A
Librarian service here at the library.
We receive over 50,000 questions a year
through Ask A Librarian, and my team,
the digital reference team,
handles about a quarter of them,
so we spend a lot of time fielding
questions that come in all across the world
from people with information needs.
>> I also am a reference librarian,
so like Abby, my job is very similar.
Another thing that we do is acquisition.
So we're also collecting books,
choosing books from around the world
in many different languages
for the collections here.
>> Would you say that people are
seeing items from the online collection
and that's driving them then to ask
questions of you where maybe before they,
you never would have encountered them?
>> I think that's true.
I think people now are realizing that the
Library of Congress has materials and services
that can actually address some of their needs,
so they might never have
even known we existed before,
but now through the internet
they actually realize
that we're a resource that
we can take advantage of.
>> And are you seeing both students
and teachers asking questions
of you online, the online system?
>> Really anybody.
>> All kinds of people --
>> All kinds of people.
>> -- all levels, elementary school on
up through people writing their Ph.D's
and sometimes they kind of expect us to do
all the research for their Ph.D's, but I,
I think you're getting just, just,
and curious people, you know,
not pinned into any particular academic hole,
but they just want to know, know some things.
>> Right. And I think the other thing about the
impact of technology is that people are so used
to Google, and they're Googling things,
but it doesn't, just because they're used
to technology doesn't mean
they're really good at searching,
and sometimes we can find things very
quickly that they've been searching
for for a long time just
because we're really good at it.
>> Right, and I think another thing that
we're good at doing is filtering information.
A lot of problems people have today, from
the students and other online searchers,
is the sheer explosion of information at their
fingertips and while that's good in many ways,
it's often difficult for them to parse out
what's credible information from what's junk,
and so one of the things that reference
librarians here can do is help put people
in touch with material that is authoritative --
>> Peer reviewed.
>> -- peer reviewed, scholarly,
that they can use in their research
and for whatever needs that they have.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.